why hello my patrons hello my patrons
the elite members of the Rob core how
are you all doing today I hope you're
doing great because in this video we're
covering fighting the Richards versus
dr. Manhattan yes we are we are going to
break down a battle between two of the
most powerful reality workers in their
respective universes and as always we're
going to look at each character
individually in terms of their origin
and their powers and then we'll conclude
by declaring a winner so Franklin
Richards was created by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and first appeared in
Fantastic Four annual number six in 1968
Franklin is the son of mr. fantastic
Reed Richards and the Invisible Woman
Susan storm which most of you guys
probably know but unlike his parents
Franklin was born with the X gene
meaning that Franklin is a mutant
however while most mutants don't
manifest their powers until adolescence
because his parents had been genetically
altered by cosmic radiation Franklin may
yet exhibiting his powers as a toddler
we first see the scope of Franklin's
abilities when he turns himself from a
child into an adult after being unable
to solve a Rubik's Cube so he simply
uses his reality-warping powers to wield
a cube to be solved at the same time he
hears the words when will you grow up on
the television and inadvertently turns
himself into an adult physically
although he does retain the mind of a
child now when he was in his adult form
we saw him for the first time in full
control of his reality-warping powers
and he's able to overcome most of the
Fantastic Four before finally realizing
what he's done and reverting back to his
child form now over the years we have
seen Franklin depicted as both a child
and an adult at various times but for
the purposes of this battle we're going
to take into account Franklin as an
adult who's in full control of his
powers because that's when he's at his
coolest now as for what his powers are
Franklin's mutant abilities center
around his psionic abilities he's
telepathic telekinetic and is able to
produce concussive psionic blasts he
also possesses precognition and astral
projection however the most significant
of Franklin's powers is that he's able
to warp reality meaning that he's able
to basically will anything he wishes
into or out of existence or change it in
any way that he can conceptualize even
as a child
Franklin demonstrated an ability to
create package universes and has on more
than one occasion he's able to affect
and neutralize the powers and abilities
of others for instance negating the
destructive quality of blackbolt voice
and turning off of
his grandfather in Faneuil Richards
brain that allowed him to time-travel he
has even shown the ability to turn the
powerful energy blast of a celestial
into a harmless stream of flowers which
was adorable Franklin has defeated
Mephisto in the demon's own realm where
he's extremely powerful even though he
was a kid at the time and he's even
turned Galactus one of the most powerful
cosmic entities in Marvel into his
Herald during Jonathan Hickman's rung on
the Fantastic Four one of the most epic
moments ever in the history of comic
books now Franklin has been able to use
his powers to increase his durability
having survived an energy blast from a
celestial as well as increase his
strength having killed a celestial with
one punch to get a sense of Franklin's
power level it's been established that
the Celestials view Franklin Richards as
an equal and Galactus has stated at the
end of time only he and Franklin will be
left with all this in mind we really
don't know the upper limits of
Franklin's powers and the only thing
that really seems to be a limitation to
his abilities is his own imagination now
on the other hand we have dr. Manhattan
now dr. Manhattan was created by Alan
Moore and Dave Gibbons and first
appeared in Watchmen number one in 1986
dr. Manhattan is the alter-ego of Jon
Osterman a PhD of atomic physics who
begins working in a field of physics
focused on figuring out the intrinsic
fields of matter which can result in
matters disintegration if altered one
day Jonathan goes back into the test
chamber to retrieve a watch and is
ultimately trapped inside when the
chamber engages resulting in the
disintegration of his body now over time
Jonathan gradually reforms his body but
when he does he does not resemble his
former self but instead is glowing blue
and has the power to manipulate matter
dr. Manhattan's matter manipulation
extends to the subatomic level which
means that much like Franklin Richards
dr. Manhattan can pretty much do
anything he wants he's built a fortress
on Mars and created an atmosphere there
so that people on the planet can breathe
he can grow his size to massive levels
and he could create multiple copies of
himself that all function independently
and simultaneously so that he can
literally be everywhere at once he can
teleport himself and others possesses
telekinesis and could disintegrate
others although dr. Manhattan is not on
mission in the strictest sense he can
observe his own past present and future
at the same time however this ability is
limited to things that he will
experience however in a battle setting
this will amount to the same sort of
free cognitive abilities of Franklin
Richards possesses as well
now dr. Manhattan remarks that he is
able to
since tachyons hypothetical particles
that can travel faster than the speed of
light and also says that he thinks he
has the ability to create human life
within the last few years it has been
revealed that dr. Manhattan has altered
the timeline of the entire DC universe
so that 10 years were missing from the
timeline since that time mr. Mitchell
pedelec an extremely adept reality
Walker has acknowledged that his power
is significantly less than that of dr.
Manhattan so as we can see both of these
characters are insanely powerful and
both are able to do almost anything they
can think of in fact both characters
have been shown to significantly alter
their respective universes so while dr.
Manhattan affected the DC timeline
Franklin was literally responsible for
recreating the entire Marvel multiverse
after it was destroyed in seeker Wars so
how do we determine a winner well it can
be difficult when we're talking about
two characters who can bend reality to
their will but we know that this is
probably not going to be a physical
battle so both combatants can alter
reality to negate any physical damage
they suffered so I think that we really
have to look at who's displayed more
prowess as a reality warper in
determining our winner if we're talking
about Franklin Richards as a child I
think there's a good chance that dr.
Manhattan would win given Franklin's
immaturity and inexperience but dealing
with an adult Franklin Richards in full
control of his powers I think he would
eventually win in a hard-fought battle
with dr. Manhattan while we have seen
dr. Manhattan transport others to other
places we've literally seen Franklin
create universes in the palm of his hand
while dr. Manhattan has claimed to
create and destroy universes what he's
really referring to is altering the
timelines of existing universes and
thereby creating new offshoot timelines
with their own universes he isn't
actually creating the matter in energy
that comprises these universes out of
nothing on the other hand this is
something that we have seen Franklin
Richards do multiple times so I think
the most likely outcome is Franklin
creating a pocket universe where
Manhattan is powerless and then
transporting him there to defeat him and
I think he would probably be able to do
that due to his telepathic ability
shutting down Manhattan's precognitive
ability so that Manhattan does not see
Franklin's planned coming I just think
that at the end of the day if we look at
what we've actually seen these
characters do we have to come to the
conclusion that Franklin is a more
proficient reality warper and therefore
give him the victory but I want to know
what you guys think here because I feel
like some hardcore dr. Manhattan fans
are going to be
I'm curious what you guys think here I
want to know what your all stance is on
this but as always thank you guys for
being patrons I love you guys so much
you all are amazing hey also leave some
comments down below on what are the
things you think we could roll into the
five dollar patreon sphere I'm
considering throwing in ad free videos
just making like ad free videos 5 bucks
a month right because in all honesty
once you get into something like patreon
and you start charging people Nilsa to
more or less watch videos without ads
then you're competing with streaming
services right so at this point I'm
competing with like Disney Plus and
Netflix and Amazon so I kind of have to
price it at a point that's like it's
it's enough to where it's it's it's
reasonable and it's fair but you guys
would be willing to pay for so give me
some ideas down there I'm working this
little on some ideas of my own but as
always I love your all's input when it
comes to this kind of stuff and yeah I
will catch you all later Bruce
[Music]
[Music]